[موسيقى]
مستمرون معكم مشاهدينا في تغطيهنا لاثار
الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا
وطبعا على الرغم من تضاؤل الفرص في العثور
على ناجين اخرين تحت الانقاض بعد دخول في
اليوم السادس اي هذا اليوم بعد الزلزال
والذي اودى بحياتي اكثر من 25 الف شخص في
احدى اسوا الكوارث التي تشهدها المنطقه
الا ان الامل يتجدد ولو قليلا مع تمكن فرق
الانقاذ في تركيا من اخراج طفلا من تحت
الركام بعد اكثر من 120 ساعه من الكارثه
منظمه دفاع المدنيه السوريه الخوذ البيضاء
اعلنت انتهاء عمليات البحث والانقاذ في
المناطق المنكوبه بالزلزال في شمال غرب
سوريا واعلنت البدء بعمليات انتشال الجثث
بعدما اصبحت فرص العثور على ناجي ناشبه
منعدمه المنظمه قالت ايضا ان حصيله
الضحايا حتى اعلان انتهاء عمليات البحث
والانقاذ بلغت اكثر من
حاله وفاه وقرابه 3000 مصاب في جميع
المناطق التي ضربها الزلزال شمال غرب
سوريا
وفي جنديرس واحده من اكثر المدن السوريه
تضرورا بالزلزال يقف اب مكلوم على اطلال
منزله وهو ينبش بين الانقاض لعله يستخرج
شيئا ما يحمل معه ذكرى لابنائه الخمسه
الذين فقدهم تحت الانقاض
[موسيقى]
اللهم اني استودعك اغلى ما املك فاحفظه لي
رساله وكتاب المدرسي هذا كل ما تبقى لهذا
الاب المكلوم من ابنته قبل موتها تحت
الانقاض ناصر الوقاح ابو سوري من مدينه
جنديرس حافظ على اسرته طيله سنوات الحرب
لكنه فقد معظمهم نتيجه الزلزال نحن
متعودون على القصر من الطائرات او
الصواريخ وحتى البراميل المتفجره لكن
الزلزال هذا بامر الله كان هذا الاب اول
الناجين من اسرته ووقف على حطام المنزل
وهو يصرخ ويقول
يا رب اترك لي واحدا فقط على الاقل واحدا
من اولاده نجح رجال القبعات البيضاء
بانقاذ اثنين من ابنائه لكن زوجته خمسه من
ابنائه لقوا حتفهم
[موسيقى]
وفي ظل هذه التطورات اكد دبلوماسيون في
الامم المتحده مجلس الامن سيناقش الاسبوع
المقبل امكانيه السماح للامم المتحده
بتوصيل مساعدات الى شمال غرب سوريا الخاضع
لسيطره المعارضه عبر اكثر من معبر حدوديا
تركي وياتي الاجتماع بعد مطالبات الامين
العام انطونيو غوتيا بارسال مساعده الى
شمال غرب سوريا عبر تركيا في المقابل اعلن
مسؤول امريكيا نواشنطن تضغط على مجلس
الامن لاعتماد قرار اخر قد يسمح بمعابر
حدوديه اضافيه لايصال المساعدات الامميه
الى المناطق المتضرره فيما ترى روسيا ان
الخطوه غير ضروريه
هذا وقد لجا قرابه 700 نازح سوري الى مخيم
مؤقت اقيم في مدرسه في مدينه الاتارب
بمحافظه حلب بعد سلسله من الزلازل العنيفه
التي قتلت واصابه الالاف في سوريا وتركيا
[موسيقى]
معنى لا مشاهدينا من ريف حلب الصحفي احمد
ابو لؤي اهلا بك يا احمد معنا احمد اذا
عمليات البحث والانقاذ انتهت في شمال غرب
سوريا والان هي عمليات رفع العقاب وانتشال
الجثث بحسب ما اعلنت الخوذ البيضاء هل
معنى ذلك بانه خلص الامل فقد تماما
بالعثور على احياء تحت الركام
نعم بالفعل بعد مرور خمسه ايام على كارثه
الزلزال الذي ضرب مناطق شماليه سوريا
المناطق ادلب بعض مناطق ادلب
مناطق ريف حلب
اعلن
الدفاع المدني فريق الدفاع المدني على
انتهاء عمليات البحث والقاد العالقين تحت
الانقار في المناطق المنكوبه بالزلزال في
شمال غير سوريا والبدء بعمليات البحث
والانتشار ومن الطبيعه عزيزتي ان ان يعني
نسبه
الوفيات ترتفع فبعد خمسه ايام يعني قرابه
اكثر من 120 ساعه يعني لا طبيعي
انخفاض نسبه الاحياء يعني
الوضع تاجر بشكل كبير طبعا الاحصائيه
الاحصائيه النهائيه للوفيات حسب الدفاع
المدني تجاوزت 2166 حاله وفاه طبعا واكثر
من 3 طبعا
المناطق التي ضربها الزلزال طبعا الحيز
الاكبر من اعداد الضحايا
يعني ذهب الى منطقه جندي عفشريين شمال حلب
حيث بلغ عدد الضحايا 513
طبعا 3 مدينه
حارم
360 حاله وفاه ثم مدينه سلقين 221
وفار طبعا بيريش ادلب اعداد المصابين ايضا
كمرتبه اولى في جنديرس حيث بلغ اعداد
المصارفين وقال
وطبعا مدينه سلقين 258
وفاه وعده مناطق اخرى
طبعا
الاوضاع اذا انتقلنا قليلا الى موضوع
المساعدات واوضاع العائلات والادويه التي
ته
دميه التي تهدمت تجاوزت تهدمت طبعا بشكل
كلي
تجاوز 500 مبنى الحيز الاكبر ايضا مدينه
جنديرس فتجاوز عدد الانديه 200 دينار بشكل
كلي
ان تكمل احمد معلش اسمح لي اني اقطعك فقط
اريد ان اذكر المشاهدين بالاخبار العاجله
التي تردنا الان اداره الكوارث التركيه
تتحدث عن اخر حصيله لضحايا هذا الزلزال
وتقول بان هذا العدد للضحايا ارتفع الى
20,665 قتيلا اذا هذا هو العدد في تركيا
عدد الضحايا من جراء هذا الزلزال اذا هو
20,675
قتيلا اعود لك مره اخرى احمد تفضل اكمل
نقطتك
كنت اتحدث عن موضوع المساعدات فيوم امس
دخل من معبر باب الهوى 14 عام حاصله قافله
مكونه من 14
شاحنه
محتواها بعض شلل النظافه والفرشاه
والبقانيات من اجل اجافه
الجرين الذي
نعم طيب ساعود لموضوع المساعدات والشاحنات
التي دخلت فقط اذكر مره اخرى مشاهدينا
بانه اداره الكوارث التركيه تقول بانه
ارتفاع عدد قتل الزلزال الى
20,665 قتيل
وعدد الاصابات ارتفع لاكثر من 93 الف مصاب
هذا في تركيا او على الاقل هذه ارقام
اداره الكوارث التركيه يا احمد هل هناك اي
ارقام شبه رسميه او اي احصاءات لعدا اعداد
الضحايا والمصابين في شمال غرب سوريا قبل
ان نكمل الحديث عن مساعدات وامور اخرى
طبعا كما ذكرت منذ قليل الحصيله النهائيه
حتى الان ما هي يعني 2166
حلب
ومناطق ريف ادلب طبعا الحزب الاسبر اخذته
مدينه جنديرس عفرين شمال حلب فانتقل الى
موضوع المساعدات وموضوع العوائل الذي بلغ
عددهم بالالاف وما زالوا تحت في العراق
وفي الاراضي الزراعيه تحت الصان الزيتون
طبعا يوم ان دخل
قافله مكونه من 14 شاحنا
بعد معاناه من عدم تفعيل المعبر للدخول
المشاهده طبعا احتوى هذه
الشاحنات على بعض خلال النظافه والبطانيات
والفرشات من اجل اغاثه المحتاجين كما دخل
12 شاحنه بقافله من كردستان العراق
مقدمه من مقدمه من مؤسسه البرزاني اضافه
اضافه من بعض مجموعات الاثار في كردستان
العراق
طريق معبر باب السلامه في مدينه شمال حلب
احتوت هذه القوافل على موارد
طبيه اضافه للشلال لكن ساذكر اليوم هنالك
الالاف والالاف من العائلات
مهجرين من منازلهم هنالك الالاف من
الابنيه التي تصدرت واصبحت غير قائله فكان
يعني او مساويه كبيره افضل وايضا هنالك
وعودات من دخول يعني اليوم
قوافل لكن حتى الان يعني لما نرى اي شيء
شحنات المساعدات بدات تدخل الى الشمال
المغرب شمال الغربي السوري كل ذلك عبر
معبر باب الهوى ام هناك معبر اخرى ايضا
تعمل
كما ذكر معبر باب الهوى هو المعبر الرسمي
يدخل عن طريق المقدمه من قبل الهيئات
الدوليه الامم المتحده وغيرها لكن
دخل 12 شاحنه
عن طريق معبر باب السلامه شمال حلب مقدمين
مؤسسه البرزاني وبعض
الفرديه
[موسيقى]
للعراق طيب احمد خلينا نعود الى موضوع
يعني المجردين او هؤلاء الذين تم انقاذهم
من تحت الانقاذ او فروا من هذه البنايات
قبل سقوطها او من اضطروا للخروج من
بناياتها بناياتها بسبب تصدعها
وخوفا من ان تسقط على رؤوسهم يعني من جراء
هذا الزلزال ذكرت بانه هم الان موجودون يا
اما في يعني حدائق عامه في في تحت تحت
اغصان الاشجار يعني هل ما الذي يحتاجون
الى خيم هل هناك اي خطط على الاقل انشاء
بعض المخيمات لايوائهم حتى يعني يتم
وصول مساعدات او او بناء اي بيوت لهم في
المستقبل
كارثه
المهجرين او الذين هجروا من منازلهم
ومباميهم
تتفاقم بعد خمسه ايام
يمكننا تقسيمهم فئه تم يعني فئه ناجين تم
انتشالهم من تحت الانقار
في المراكز الصحيه في المستشفيات في
المستوصفات طبعا يعني
للعلم ان الواقع الطبي ايضا صعب ويتفاقم
بما شاف هنالك يعني
افتقار
بكثير من اول العديد من الامور الطبيه
هنالك الكوادر الطبيه المعدات اضافه علميه
اما بالنسبه للفئه الاخرى الذين هجروا من
ابليتهم يعني في لحظه الجلزال او لحظه
الحدث والذين هذا وهراء وخوفان
اليوم نجدهم فئه نجدها يعني لربما عند
اقاربهم في منازل عربيه او احواش عربيه
التي تعتبر اقل عرضه للخطر
ايه هزار ارتداديه ما زال تحت طبعا حتى
الان
والشيعه الاكبر مع شخص مشردين حتى الان
تحت اقفال الزيتون
في الاراضي الوعره وايضا في البعض او يتم
انشاء يعني
البعض من المخيمات بجهود او مجموعات
فرديه بتبرعات خارجيه من اشخاص متواجدين
بشمال غرب سوريا يعني الوضع كبير يجب
تداخل الدول من اجل اضافه هؤلاء المقيومين
المهجرين من منازلهم بسبب هذا الزلزال
حاول احتياجاتهم الاساسيه وهم الان في
العراء يعني في بعض الصور على ما يبدو بان
هناك بعض يعني الجهود
لتوفير
الطعام وايضا الشراب لهم ماذا بالنسبه
لذلك يعني من يطعمهم
نعم كما ذكرت منذ قليل يعني اليوم
حاجه
بالمرتبه الاولى بحاجه الى هي طبعا
للمهجرين متواجدين في العراق الى
البطانيات للفرشار طبعا
لمواد التدفئه من بالنسبه لموضوع الطعام
وما شابه ذلك يتم بجهود
او مجموعات يجمعون مبالغ من قبل
تجار من قبل طبعا
افراد من اجل
اطعامهم من يعني يقومون بتحضير وجبات
وتوزيعها الى هؤلاء المهجرين الموجودين في
الاراضي الزراعيه و
غيرها عن طريق طبعا مجموعه يجب المصارعه
المصارعه
[موسيقى]
الضوء من قبل الدول من قبل
المنظمات الدوليه من قبل
طبعا الدول التي تعهدت بادخال مساعدات
لهذه المناطق يعني من اجل اغاحه هؤلاء
الاشخاص
ولربما
تاسيس او بناء لهم لو مراكز تاويهم بشكل
مؤقت في هذا البرد القارس يعني انا ذكرت
منذ قليلهم
للحاجيات الاسعافيه كخيمه وما شابه
بطانيات وغيرها لكن يعني الخيمه تعتبر
يعني هي شيء مؤقت هي شيء مؤقت اكثر ولا
اقل لازم ما يجب تخفيض الضوء مبدئيا
لتاسيس او بناء مراكز
العائلات المشربه يعني هو الحل الانسب
لانهاء الماتشات وعدم تكرار ما شاف جديده
مثل المعاش القديمه التي يتعرض لها
المهجرين السوريين شكرا جزيلا لك من ريف
حلب الصحفيه احمد ابو لؤي
انقذ رجال الاغاثه امراه حامل في شهرها
السادس وابنتها البالغه من العمر سبع
سنوات بعد قضاء 115 ساعه بينك ومن انقاذ
مبنى سوي بالارض في مدينه غازي عنتاب
التركيه اثر الزلزال
اه مشاهدينا في الاخبار العاجله التي
تاتينا الان الخوذ البيضاء تقول للعربيه
لا مؤشرات على وجود احياء تحت الانقاض في
سوريا اذا الخوض البيضاء تفقد الامل تماما
بوجود احياء تحت الانقاض في سوريا وتقول
بانه لا توجد اي مؤشرات على ذلك ونحن الان
في اليوم السادس بعد وقوع هذا الزلزال
معنى لا مشاهدينا من القامش لمراسل
العربيه جمعه عكاش اهلا بك يا جمعه جمعه
صف لنا الصوره لديك الان
صباح الخير لكاده المشاهدين يعني منذ ليله
امس وحتى الان
حصل بعض من الامل بعد انتشال شخصين احياء
في مبنى الريحاوي بمدينه جبله في الساحل
السوري في هذا المبنى ايضا تم انتشال 43
جثه يعني
على قيد الحياه اضافه الى الاعمال تجري
للبحث عن تسعه اشخاص اخرين في هذا المبنى
لا يزال مصيرهم مجهولا
الى اللاذقيه هناك ايضا يعني محاولات
للبحث عن ناجين لكن دون اي جدوى لبعض من
الجسد في هذه المدينه التي تشبع يعني
ارتفاع كبير في اعداد الموتى اما الى في
مدينه حلب بقي مبنى واحد وخلال اقل من
ساعتين ستونه فريق يعني البحث والانقاذ
رفع ركام هذا المبنى لتكون الاعمال في
مركز مدينه حلبه تابعه للنظام بينما في
مناطق المعارضه اعمال فرق الدفاع المدني
استمرت بوتيره بطيئه في بلدات سلقين
وحارب والاتارب وايضا في جنديرس التي عادت
الوتيره للارتفاع
بشروق الشمس صباح هذا اليوم طبعا فرق
الدفاع المدني انتقلت من مرحله
الانقاذ اي البحث عن ناجين الى مرحله
الانتشار الانتشار الجثث بعد ان يعني شعرت
بان فرص العثور على احياء اصبحت معدومه
تسعى الاطلاق العمل في هذه البلده ليشمل
حوالي او اكثر من نصف المباينه ونتحدث
الان عن تقريبا 45
مبنى وصلتها اعمال فرق الانقاذ من اصل 84
مبنى مهدم الوصول الى المباني الاخرى في
هذه المرحله سيكون اسهل وتحريكام سيكون
لا يزال الضغط كبير على جميع المراكز
الطبيه في عموم المدن السوريه المنكوبه
هناك حالات حرجه يعني تحتاج الى نوع من
التعامل الطبي الخاص خاصه اولئك الذين
يعانون من كسور في العمود الفقري او بثرت
اطرافهم يحتاجون الى نقلهم من المناطق
المنكوبه الى الى خارج الى خارج بلاد سوى
الى تركيا او الى دول اخرى ويمكن ايضا
نقلهم الى مشافي تتوفر فيها الكوادر
الطبيه في دمشق وايضا في القامش في مناطق
الاكراد لكن حتى الان لم يتم ذلك هناك
ايضا يعني مصابون
بالفشل الكلوي يعني تم انتشالهم من
الانقاض خاصه في اليوم الثالث والرابع من
الزلزال نتيجه البرد حدث معه فشل الكلوي
وايضا لا توجد مشاكل متخصصه خاصه في مناطق
يعني همم رئه ريافه ادلب وحلب يحتاجون الى
نقل سريع لكن حتى هذه اللحظات لم نرصد اي
يعني حالات لنقل هؤلاء الذين يعانون من
اصابات حرجه الى خارج المناطق المنكوبه
سوى الى دمشق او القامشه او حتى الى تركيا
نحن جزيلا لك من القامشلي مراسل العربيه
جمعه عكاش
حضرت منظمه اليونيسف من مخاطر انتشار واسع
للامراض المنقوله بواسطه المياه عقب
الزلزال المدمر في تركيا وسوريا في وقت
يثير فيه نقص الوقود والكهرباء والمياه
النظيفه مخاوف جمعيات الاغاثه الخيريه وفق
موقع اكسبرس البريطاني
من نجا من فتك الزلزال به وبمنزله قد لا
ينجو من كارثه صحيه تتربص به الكوليرا عدو
اخر يهدد سوريا وتركيا
ناقوس الخطر دقته منظمه اليونيسف التي
حذرت من مخاطر انتشار واسع للامراض
المنقوله بواسطه المياه حيث تبقى مخاطر
الاصابه بامراض مثل الكوليرا
والاسهالتاريا في اعلى مستوياتها على
الاطلاق في اعقاب كارثه الزلزال في سوريا
تم اعلان تفشي الكوليرا قبل خمسه اشهر في
اعقاب الزلزال ربما تكون مصادر المياه
النظيفه القليله المتاحه قد تضررت ايضا
قلق عالمي يتزايد اذا انتشار وباء
الكوليرا الذي ظهر مجددا في سوريا
والارقام تحكي عن رصد 84 الف حاله كوليرا
منذ سبتمبر الماضي حتى بدايه هذا العام
المعطيات وفق المنظمات الصحيه تشير الى
ازدياد الحالات ان لم تتم معالجه الشبكات
المتضرره بالسرعه الممكنه
الحال نفسها في تركيا وان كانت بدرجات اقل
المياه غمرت شوارع بعض المناطق المتضرره
من الزلزال وسط تقارير غربيه تشير الى نقص
حاد في المياه الصالحه للشرب في تلك
المناطق
الامر الذي يضاعف الخسائر وينذر بكارثه
صحيه اخرى قبل الاستفاقه من صدمه الكارثه
الزلزال
رغم الجهود الكبيره التي تدلها فرق
الانقاذ والمتطوعين والمتطوعين ايضا الا
ان تصرفات بسيطه قد تنقذ حياه وتغير حياه
اخرى ظنت ان الوقت قد فاتها من اجل لقاء
ولو فرقوا لقائي ولو فردا واحد من العائله
هذه الصوره انتشرت وشاهدها وسط مقاطع
المصائب ملايين السوريين رغم الكدمات
والجروح طفل يلتهم وجبته الاولى بعد ايام
من البرد والجوع تحت الركام لقب بطفل
الموزه لكنها لم تكن بالنسبه لابراهيم
مجرد موزه بعد انقاذه من تحت الركام نقل
لمستشفى عفرين حالته كانت حرجه واعتبر
الناجي الوحيد من عائلته احدهم قرر نشر
الفيديو عملا بان يصل قريب له او جار
صدفناه بمشفى عفرين ما كان في لا اب ولا
ام لحاله وحيد اعطيناه موزه اماكن بطريقه
يعني ما بتتخيلو عطشان
فصورناه فيديو ونشرناه على السوشيال ميديا
وقلنا اذا حدا بيعرفوه ما الى ذلك
ما كان معجزه تحول الى حقيقه اما اللقاء
فقد رافقته دموع الفرح عاد الاب للبكاء
بعد ان جفت عيناه حزنا على زوجته وابنه
البكر كغيره من ابناء حيه اقتصر الامل في
العثور على قريب يكسر وحشه بات تهددهم بها
الحياه الاف السوريين باتوا غرباء لاهل
لهم في بلداتهم الحمد لله رب العالمين
تركت طاقه عم بتنفس منها فقد ابراهيم امه
وربما لن يحمل لها معه ذكرى لقائه بوالده
لن يكون كافيا للجمع بينهما الاب باتا دون
ماوى لكن الطفل المعجزه وجد الحنان في
عائله سوريه ربما هي الاخرى لا تمتلك
الكثير لكن خيمه ومدفاه بتتا تختزلان كل
احلام المنكوبين
يا روحي
مع وقوع الزلزال المدمر في تركيا وسوريا
اسعار رجال الانقاذ للاستعانه بكل ما يمكن
من حيوانات او ادوات للوصول الى ناجين تحت
الانقاض لا سيما انا عمليات البحث خلال
هذه الكوارث من اصعب عمليات الانقاذ
واكثرها او اكثرها تعقيدا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الصمت هنا مختلف ليس كاي صمت حتى انه عرف
بصمت الموت فعلى طريق النجاه ينادي
المنقذون بصوت واحد ثم يصمتون جميعا
وسيله استخدمها المنقذون للعثور على
ناجيين في سوريا وعلى قله الامكانيات ولو
كان الامل ضعيفا بوجود انفاس تحت هذه
الانقاض يحاول عمال البحث بطرق بدائيه
وتقليديه
في ظل تعقيد البحث وصعوبه الوصول وسماع
الناجين تحت اقوام الركام تطورت ادوات
البحث لنجده العالقيين فاعتمد الخبراء على
تقنيات تكنولوجيه تطورت عبر الزمن ومن
ابرزها الفئران والصراصير المزوده
بكاميرات صغيره القادره على الدخول الى
امكنه لا يمكن رؤيتها او حتى سماع اصوات
تطلب استغاثه الافعى الروبوت على شكل
ثعبان يستطيع صعود درجات عاليه والتنقل
عبر المساحات الضيقه تقنيه حديثه يسعى
الباحثون لاستخدامها الطائرات المسيره
بامكانها فصل الاحياء عن الاموات عن طريق
الكشف عن حركه بسيطه للضحايا وحده فايندر
تاتي بحجم حقيبه اليد ترسل موجات دقيقه
منخفضه الطاقه ويمكن ان تكشف الموجات عن
خفيه مثل النبض الخفيف للجلد الذي يكشف عن
دقات القلب
مشعلا مصباحه ينادي مسابقا الزمن اعلى
صوته ينجح في انقاذ عالق من قبضه تلك
الانقاض بشتى الطرق وباي طريقه كانت يحاول
ولا يزال
عصام عبد السلام العربيه
وفيما تتضائل فرص الوصول الى ناجين بعد
مرور خمسه ايام على الزلزال المدمر الذي
ضرب تواصل فرقه وتواصل طلبه طبعا تركيا
وسوريا تواصل اذا فرق الانقاذ عمليات
البحث في مدينه كرمان مرعش مركز الزلزال
على امل انقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه في اللحظات
الاخيره
هنا مركز الزلزال هنا كهرمان مرعش حيث
الانقاض حبلى بالقتله والعالقين هنا انقاذ
وانتظار وكثير من البكاء
وفي المشهد ستيني ينتظر ولاده ابنه من فم
الموت
ابني هنا وعائلته مكونه من سته اشخاص
اخرجوا شخصا واحدا فقط على قيد الحياه
والاعمال مستمره لانقاذهم ولا معلومات
عنهم حتى الان
وفي هذا الحي سوريون هربوا من ويلات الحرب
قبل سنوات هربوا من الموت الى موت اخر
والله ان ثلاثه اشخاص تحت انقاذ صار لنا
شي يومين لسه ما طلعنا منهم اي خبر او اي
نتيجه في كهرمان مرعش اختلطت الدماء تحت
انقاض اكثر من 940 بنايه سويت بالارض تمر
ساعات والايام وتتضاءل فرص نجاه العالقين
وفي الذاكره صور لاحبه حجم الكارثه فاق
زلزال مرمره عام 99 والصوره كافيه واصدقوا
انباء وفي الصوره ايضا يمكن نقل اعداد
الموتى والجرحى والمصابين والدمار والدموع
لكن وحدها رائحه الموت على امتداد 10
ولايات لا يمكن نقلها
العربيه كهرمان مرعش
تواعد الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
باتخاذ اجراءات عقابيه قاسيه بحق من
يهاجمون الاسواق والمحلات التجاريه
وينهبون السلع والمواد منها
مباني مدمره محلات تساوت بالارض والاخرى
بقيت صامده عدا نوافذها المحطمه
يتسابق من بقي في هذه المدن المتضرره من
الزلزال الى اكوام من الصناديق البعض بحثا
عن الاحتياجات الاساسيه واخرون استغلوا
الوضع الصعب للسرقه والنهب هنا نرى من
يخرج راكضا من محل تجاري بيده اساسيات
غذائيه او استهلاكيه وبالمقابل مشهد
لاخرين يخرجون اما خليل وفاظ او بغنائمه
كبيره مهما كانت اسبابه ومبرراته اولئك
الاشخاص الذين وثقت سرقاتهم عبر مقاطع
فيديو ملات مواقع التواصل الا ان الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان اكد انه بالمرصاد
مستنكرا استغلال البعض للظروف الصعبه
الحاليه
مع الاسف هناك بعض الناس الذين يهاجمون
الاسواق والمحلات التجاريه وينهبون السلع
والمواد الدوله اتخذت التدابير وخطوات
ضدها هؤلاء وستتم معاقبتهم باشد الطرق
الرئيس التركي اعلن قبل ايام حاله الطوارئ
في البلاد لمده ثلاثه اشهر حاله قال انها
ستساهم في مساعده المدن المنكوبه والحد من
اعمال النهب والسرقه
روان حمزه العربيه
معنى لا مشاهدينا من اسطنبول المحلله
السياسي دكتور سمير صالحه اهلا بك دكتور
سمير معنا دكتور سمير اذا اداره الكوارث
التركيه تتحدث عن ارتفاع قتل او عدد قتل
الزلزال في تركيا الى 20,65 واكثر من 93
الف مصاب في بعض المناطق تم الاعلان عن
انتهاء عمليات البحث والانقاذ والان فقط
انتشال الجثث ورفع للانقاض متى نتوقع بانه
يعني خلص ستنتهي عمليات البحث في كافه
المناطق السوريه التركيه عفوا خصوصا ونحن
الان في اليوم السادس من او بعد هذا
الزلزال
صحيح صباح الخير للجميع اولا يعني طبعا
الان هو زمن المعجزات كما يبدو لانه كما
اشرت في اليوم السادس حوالي 120 ساعه
تقريبا على على الزلزال وعمليات البحث عن
ناجين تحت الانقاد مستمره قبل حوالي ساعه
ونصف من الان ايضا في ديار بكر حصلت
المعجزه وتم انقاذ سيده في تلك البقعه
الجغرافيه ايضا فجرا جاءت انباء جديده عن
انقاذ
الاشخاص تحت الانقاد في
كهرمان مرعش فيها يعني ما زالت يعني
الاعمال الموجوده والفرق الانقاذ
فوق الركام تحاول البحث عن نجم لكن اتفق
معك يعني كلما
تقدم الزمن كلما تقلصت فرص العثور على
احياء الان بعد الانتهاء من عمليه
البحث عن ناجين وربما هذه تستمر ليومين او
ثلاثه ايام اضافيه ستبدا عمليه ازاله
الاركان والركام والدخول في البحث عن
الخطط في اطار الدائره الثانيه الدائره
الثانيه يعني البحث عن ايواء
مؤقت للناجين تامين الخدمات الصحيه
الماديه لهم طبعا يعني مع رفع ربما
الانقاض وانتهاء عمليات البحث من المرجح
بانه سيكون سيتم العثور على للاسف يعني
ناس اناس فقدوا حياتهم تحت الانقاض وهذا
الرقم
20665 قتيل في تركيا من المرجح ان يزداد
ولكن بما انك ذكرت المرحله الثانيه او
الحلقه الثانيه وهي العنايه بمن بقوا على
قيد الحياه 93 الف جريح رقم مهول وضخم جدا
كيف تتعامل او يتعامل القطاع الصحي التركي
مع ذلك مع هذا الرقم وهل هو قادر على
استيعابها
يعني طبعا تركيا عندها تجارب في قطاع
الخدمات الصحيه في داخل الاراضي التركيه
وفي خارجها لذلك انا لا اظن اطلاقا انه
سيكون هناك اي مشكله في التعامل مع
المصابين والجرح الذين يتم نقلهم الى اكثر
من مدينه تركيا في المناطق المجاوره
للمناطق الزلزال او في مدن بعيده الى جانب
ذلك كما تعرفين
في تجهيز العديد من المستشفيات الميدانيه
الان التي تقدم
الخدمات
داخل هذه المناطق يعني من الناحيه الصحيه
المساله لن تكون اطلاقا صعبه لكن
الاهم الان هو برايك مساعده الناس على على
صحيح الاماكن البديله يعني الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان كان يتحدث الامس في مؤتمر صحفي او
يعني وهو يعني يقوم بجوله ميدانيه ربما
المناطق المتضرره بانه سيتم بناء بيوت
خلال سنه
لهؤلاء لكل من فقدوا بيوتهم ومنازلهم من
جراء هذا الزلزال ولكن حتى ذلك الحين ما
هي الخطه الحكوميه
لايواء هؤلاء
وتقديم المساعدات لهم صحيح كما تبعت لي
انت ايضا في اخر مؤتمر صحفي لمساعد الوزير
الخارجيه التركي فؤاد تحدث انه تم نقل
عشرات الالاف من داخل الدائره الاولى
منطقه الزلزال الى خارج هذه المناطق وتمت
المساعده على ايجاد هذه الاماكن البديله
لهم فنادق فتحت ابوابها
تستقبلهم العديد من المخيمات التي انشات
بشكل سريع مساعده ماديه تقدم لهم للبحث عن
اماكن يستاجرونها في في خطه مبرمجه الان
جديده يتم التعامل معها لكن علينا ان ناخذ
بعين الاعتبار انا وانت ايضا العدد الكبير
للاشخاص الذين يبحثون الان عن مدينه لعدد
الناس الذين هجروا دعنا نقول من منازلهم
من جراء هذا الزلزال
فؤاد قال انه في مليون مواطن الان ينتظرون
الايواء وقال انه 185 الف مواطن تم نقلهم
الى الدائره الثانيه يعني خارج منطقه
الزلزال
النقطه الاهم الان هي برايي انه التعامل
مع الاحتياجات احتياجات الاساسيه لهؤلاء
الاشخاص الذين يتم نقلهم الخطه التي اشرت
اليها التي اتحدث عنها الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان بناء مساكن بديله ايضا تدخل في
اطار المعجزه 12 شهر خلال 12 شهر سيتم
تجهيز الابنيه البديله لذلك تستحق هذه
المساله جهود براي جباره ضخمه من ناحيه
التمويه من ناحيه التجهيز التخطيط يعني كل
هذه المسائل الان تدرس من قبل القياده
السياسيه التركيه طيب دكتور سمير ايضا
يعني هناك الكثير من البنايات لم تسقط تم
اخلائها لانها تصدعت وتضررت بشكل كبير ما
هي الخطه بالنسبه لهذه البنيه بنايات هل
سيتم تدميرها وبنائها من جديد ام اصلاحها
ام ماذا
يعني طبعا ما تعرفين انت ايضا سيكون مرتبط
بالتقارير الفنيه التي سيقدمها خبراء حول
وضعيه
الابنيه لكن رايي الشخصي طالما انه الحديث
يجري عن بناء مدن او مناطق جديده
اظن سيكون هناك مراجعه شامله يعني كل بناء
الان معرض للسقوط
في مشاكل الفنيه
ما هو ملفت بانه حتى في المناطق التي كانت
في مركز الزلزال لم تسقط كل الابنيه بعض
البنايات سقطت وبالتالي هذه الكارثه حصلت
البعض الاخر ظل واقفا معنى ذلك بان هناك
تفاوت ايضا في البنى التحتيه على ما يبدو
رغم انه يعني معروف بانه الكثير من
المناطق التركيه تقع فوق خط صدى كبير
ويتعرض للزلازل بشكل كبير هل يمكن ان يكون
هناك مراجعه لطريقه البناء اصلا لتتحمل
يعني حدوث زلازل من المتوقع ان تكون
متكرره في المستقبل
وبالتالي تدارك مثل هذه الكارثه صحيح مثل
هذه المراجعه كان من المفترض ان تحدث ان
تتم قبل سنوات طالما انه موضوع الزلازل
والكوارث الطبيعيه في تركيا دائما هو في
قلب النقاش والتركيز كان على تفعيل دور
منظمه وهيئه الاغاثه رئاسه الاغاثه افراد
الان
في عندنا مسائله جديده ستبدا يعني بعد
الخروج من هذه الازمه هذه الكارثه في
الاسابيع المقبله سنناقش بشكل موسع تحميل
المسؤوليات تحديد المسؤوليات ما الذي جرى
لماذا بهذا الشكل المشكله الاساسيه التي
سنركز عليها في النقاشات براي ستكون مساله
الحالات اسباب اعلان العفو العام عن بعض
الابنيه التي اخلت بالمعايير المطلوبه من
ناحيه الفنيه وهذا سيكون في قلب المشهد
بين القيادات السياسيه في الحكم في
المعارضه وبين العديد من النقابات
المتخصصه في هذا المجال طب دكتور سمير
هناك نقطه اخرى مهمه جدا ربما لا يتم
الحديث عنها كثيرا في هذه المرحله من هول
الصدمه وهول الكارثه ولكنها ستشكل مشكله
اكبر ربما في الايام
والسنوات القادمه وهي طبعا هؤلاء من تم
انتشالهم من تحت الانقاض الذين فقدوا
الكثير من عائلاتهم كثير من الاطفال
اليتامى الان اصبحوا بلا ليس فقط بلا ماوى
بلا ام ولا اب ولا بلا رعايه ناهيك طبعا
عن حتى من سلم جسده لن يسلم عقله او قلبه
معنى بانه يعني الاضرار النفسيه بعد هذه
الكارثه وهذا الهول الكبير ستكون ممتده هل
هناك اي خطط لمعالجه هذا الامر او على
الاقل محاوله ايجاد حلول
يعني كما تعرفين انت ايضا تركيا مرت باكثر
من تجربه من هذا النوع في زلازل وحالات
ايضا لا تختلف كثيرا عن الحاله التي
نعيشها ونناقشها الان لذلك انا من الناحيه
التعاطي مع حالات من هذا النوع في عنا
خبراء وخبره وسيعه سواء كان في المجال
النفسي في المجال الصحي في مجال الاجتماعي
التعليمي في عنا اكثر من مؤسسه تدخل بشكل
سريع على الخط وتتعمل مع هذه الحالات
وفيها نجاح كبير على الارض لكن اتفق معك
يعني حجم الازمه الان كبير يحتاج الى جهود
جباره في هذا الحقل ايضا لمساعده هؤلاء
الان الاطفال الذين خرجوا من تحت الانقاد
بدون اسرهم
المساله تتطلب جهد اضافي في اكثر من من
اتجاه اسباب
[موسيقى]
طبعا يعني الان يعني كما تبعنا في الايام
الاخيره التي مرت لم يكن هناك اي تمييز
بين
مواطن تركي مواطن سوريا او غير مواطن يحمل
جنسيه اخرى يعني نحن كان تقديم العامل
الانساني هو الاساس في كل هذه الجهود التي
بذلت ربما من الناحيه التقنيه او الناحيه
السياسيه من ناحيه
التفاهمات الاقليميه والدوليه الحاله في
تركيا اختلفت عن الحاله في في سوريا لكن
بالنسبه للسوريين الذين
يتواجدون داخل الاراضي التركيه تمت
معاملتهم في اطار انه بين المنكوبين وبين
المتضررين من هذا الزلزال وتم تقديم كافه
الخدمات الصحيه الايوائيه والدعم المادي
لهم شكرا جزيلا لك من اسطنبول المحلله
السياسي دكتور سمير صالحه
[موسيقى]
في محاولات اطقمه لانقاذ البحث عن عجينه
تحت الانقاض برزت عده طرق يستخدمونها اكثر
من غيرها نتعرف عليها مع مراسلنا زيدان
زنجلو من اضنه جنوب تركيا
في المواقع المدمره نتيجه الزلزال الذي
ضرب تركيا تعتمد فرق الانقاذ على عده طرق
للتاكد مما اذا كان هناك ناجين تحت
الانقاض ام لا اولا الطريقه التقليديه
التي يقوم من خلالها احد رجال الانقاذ
باصدار نداءات متكرره بعد فتح فجوه بين
الركام وينتظر حتى يسمع ردا من الداخل في
حال لم يصله رد تلجا الفرق الى الطريقه
الثانيه وهي الكلاب المدربه التي تستشعر
وجود احياء كذلك تلجا فرق الانقاذ الى
استخدام كاميرات المراقبه الحراريه التي
تستطيع تحديد اماكن العالقين تحت الانقاض
طبعا نحن نصور هذا التقرير بعد انتهاء
تطبيق هذه الطرق لان الصمت والهدوء التام
شرط اساسي لنجاح هذه الطرق زيدان زنجلو
اضنه
قالت منظمه الصحه العالميه ان الزلزال عاد
الى الواجهه ما وصفته بالازمه المنسيه في
سوريا واكدت انها مستعده لارسال مساعدات
كبيره الى سوريا لكنها تواجه الكثير من
القيود واضافت الصحه العالميه بان حجم
الكارثه في سوريا كبير للغايه ويفوق قدره
الجميع واشارت الصحه العالميه لان الزلزال
الذي دمر اجزاء كبيره من المدن في سوريا
اعاد تسليط الضوء على سوريا التي تعاني
اصلا
كما قال المدير التنفيذي لبرامج الطوارئ
بمنظمه الصحه العالميه قال ان العالم كان
قد نسي سوريا لكن الزلزال اعاد الانتباه
الى الازمه هناك
الان لفت الزلزال الانتباه لكن العالم نسي
سوريا بصراحه اعاد الزلزال الانتباه لكن
هؤلاء الملايين من الناس في سوريا يكافحون
منذ السنوات واصبحوا في ازمه منسيه لذلك
في الواقع ومن المفارقات ان الزلزال هو
ماساه مروعه ولكنه يعيد الانتباه على
الاقل الى الاحتياجات الاوسع للسكان
طالبت رئيسه لجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر
ماريانا سبولياريتش بعدم عرقله العمل
الانساني وعدم تسييس المساعدات الانسانيه
الموجهه للمتضررين جراء الزلزال في تركيا
وسوريا واضافت في تصريح عقب زياره زياره
قادتها الى حلب ان صليب الاحمر سيبدر قصار
جهده لدعم الناس اينما كانوا الا انها دعا
جميع الاطراف الى اساحه الوصول الكامل
للمساعدات الانسانيه
هذا وعربه رئيسه اللجنه الدوليه للصليب
الاحمر عندهشتها من حجم الدمار الذي اصاب
مدينه حلب كما اكدت ان الصليب الاحمر
سيبدله كل ما في وسعه لتقديم الدعم لمن هم
في حاجه اليها
من الصعب جدا وصف المعاناه والدمار الذين
شهدتهما هنا في حلب الطقس بارد جدا ولا
توجد تدفئه قلبي ينفطر على كل من فقد
احبائه والاباء الذين فقدوا اطفالهم
والاطفال الذين فقدوا ذويهم من الصعب رؤيه
معاناه الاطفال وكبار السن بشكل خاص ستبذل
اللدنه الدوليه كلما في وسعها لدعمهم
خلال زلزال عام 1906 تزحزحت منطقه الزلزال
نحو سته امتار وفي تركيا نفسها تزحزح صدع
الاناضول خلال زلزال ازميت عام 1999 اكثر
من اثنين ونصف من الامتار اما اليوم اشار
علماء جيولوجيا الى ان جانبا من صفيحه
الاناضول تحرك لحوالي ثلاثه امتار لكن كيف
تتحرك الصفائح التكتونيه
زلزال في السادس من فبراير كان ضخما جدا
وفي المناطق المنكوبه من الصعب على
الناجين فهم حجم ما حدث وهذا ما تحدثوا
عنه لكن لفهم ما جرى بالضبط سنتخيل ان سطح
الارض هو عباره عن احجيه عن الطبقه
الخارجيه منها ليست متصله هي مكونه من
صفائح ضخمه تقريبا عشرون عشرين قطعه
متداخله مع بعضها البعض وبنفس الشكل الذي
تتخذه الاحجيات لكنها تستمر في الحركه
وببطء وبمعدل سنتيمتر الى 20 في السنه اما
ان تتباعد او تصطدم ببعضها او تنزلق عبر
حدودها
ما احدث الزلزال الاول وما تلاه منطقيا
كان تحركا عنيفا تمزق على اثره امتداد
الصدع بين صفيحتي الاناضول والعربيه التي
تقع تركيا على خطوطه مع الصفيحه الوراثيه
ايضا تركيا تحركت مشاهدينا بثلاثه امتار
خلال ثواني نعم الجغرافيا تغيرت البلد
باكمله تحرك نحو الغرب
غير او تغير مكانه
[موسيقى]
سنواصل معكم مشاهدينا تغطيهنا للزلزال لكن
نتوقف امام بعض الاخبار الخاصه بملفات
اخرى ففي مقابله مع العربيه قال وزير
الخارجيه العراقي فؤاد حسين ان امن
المنطقه مهم للعراق مشددا في ذات الوقت
على ضروره خلق حالات تفاهميه بين ايران
ودول الاخرى حسين اضاف ان العراقي يمكنه
بفضل علاقاته الجيده مع دول الجوار ان
يستطيع لم الجميع حول طويله مستديره عمل
المنطقه
يخصنا جميعا
ولهذا نحاول خلق حاله تفاهميه على تفاهميه
بين ايران ودول الاخرى وحتى بين الدول
الاخرى
وتركيا في زمانها
العراق يلعب هذا الدور المركزي والمحوري
لدينا مشاكل مع بعض الدول الجوار ولكن
نتيجه علاقاتنا جيده مع جميع دول الجوار
نستطيع ان نجمع الجميع حول طاوله
المستديره
افرزت السلطات الايرانيه عن الباحثه
الفرنسيه الايرانيه فريبه عدد الخاه التي
اوقفت في ايران في يونيو 2019 وصدر في
مايو 2020 حكم بسجنها خمسه اعوام لادانتها
بتهم تمس الامن القومي وقالت الخارجيه
الفرنسيه في بيان ان الباحثه الفرنسيه
اطلق سراحها من سجن افين وانه من الضروري
ان تستعيد حريتها بالكامل بما في ذلك
العوده الى فرنسا
اعلن رئيس مجموعه العسكريه الروسيه الخاصه
ضروره ان تسيطر القوات الروسيه على مدينه
بخمت الاستراتيجيه للمضي قدما في حملتها
لافتا الى ان القوات الروسيه تواجه مقاومه
شرسه من قبل الجيش الاوكراني واضاف في
مقابله
ان على روسيا ان تضع اهدافا واضحه في
حملتها العسكريه تعتمد على ترسيخ وجودها
بقوه شرق اوكرانيا او المضي قدما للسيطره
على المزيد من الاراضي
اعلنت اوكرانيا سيده عدد من مواقع الطاقه
بعشرات الصواريخ الروسيه وطائرات مسيره
محمله بالمتفجرات في هجوم الروسيه المكثف
تقول كيا فينا موسكو تسعى من ورائه الى
تدمير مصادر الطاقه في اوكرانيا واكدت
وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه نصارخين عبرال
الجوي لرومانيا فيما قالت بوخارست التي
نفت الخبر ان اجهزتها رصدت صاروخين عبر
على مسافه 35 كم من اراضيها
اعلنت المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض كارين
او
ان الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن سيزور بولندا
في الفتره ما بين العشرين الى للثاني
والعشرين من فبراير الجري وذلك قبيل ذكرى
الاولى للحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا واوضحت
ان بايدن يلتقي في اطار الزياره نظيره
البولنديه اندريه لبحث التعاون الثنائي
والجهود المشتركه لدعم اوكرانيا وتعزيز
قدرات الردع في حلف شمال الاطلسي
طائره مقاتله امريكيه اسقطت هدفا فوق
العسكر في الساعه الماضيه باوامر مباشره
من الرئيس واوضح كاربي ان هذا الجسم الذي
قال انه بحجم سياره صغيره شكل تهديدا لامن
الملاحه الجويه
الرئيس دائما يتصرف بالطريقه التي تهدف
الى حمايه مصالح الامريكيين والامن القومي
الاسبوع الماضي تحدثنا عن هدف تم اسقاطه
بنجاح بعد ان حلق فوق الاجواء الامريكيه
واليوم ايضا نتحدث عن هدف لا نعرف تفاصيله
لكنه كان يمثل تهديدا محتملا لسلامه
الطيران المدني بالنظر الى الارتفاع الذي
كان يحلق عليه
شركات صينيه الى لائحتها السوداء بعد
تدميرها من طالا صينيا قالت انهم مجهز
بادوات تجسس وكان يحلق فوق مواقع عسكريه
حساسه ما يعني منع تلك الشركات من الوصول
الى تقنيات والسلع الامريكيه من دون اذن
واقل نائب وزيره التجاره دون
غريبز ان اللائحه السوداء للولايات
المتحده التي شملت الشركات الصينيه ست
تعتبر اداه قويه لتحديد ومنع الجهات التي
تسعى لاستخدام وصولها الى الاسواق
العالميه لالحاق الضرر بالامن القومي
الامريكي وتهديده
وهذه التغطيه مشاهدينا مستمره عبر العربيه
لكارثه الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا
وسوريا اشكركم حسن المتابعه واترك هذه
التغطيه الان مع الزملاء من الرياض الى
اللقاء